el presidente chileno sebastián piñera
anunció el domingo por la noche la
postergación de las elecciones previstas
para el 10 y el 11 de abril que pasarán
a celebrarse ahora el 15 y el 16 de mayo
a través de una reforma constitucional
que ha de ser aprobada en el congreso se
trata de una decisión difícil afirmó el
mandatario que se toma en función de dos
objetivos proteger la salud de los
chilenos y proteger también la
democracia las altas tasas de contagio
que se han producido en el país en los
últimos días podrían inhibir que muchas
personas acudieran a votar y restar así
tanto participación como legitimidad a
un proceso histórico en el que 155
chilenos serán elegidos para elaborar
una constitución y se elegirán también
alcaldes concejales y gobernadores cada
vez serán más voces en los últimos días
los que apostaban por aplazar estas
elecciones ante la crítica situación
sanitaria que atraviesa el país chile
vive su peor momento en la pandemia
hasta ahora con cuatro días consecutivos
en los que se han superado los siete mil
casos de contagios a diario y que
podrían traducirse en ingresos en las
unidades de cuidados intensivos que ya
se encuentran completamente desbordadas
a un 95 96 por ciento de su capacidad
de la salud muy mermados entre un 25 y
un 30 por ciento de ellos tienen
licencias médicas en muchos casos
asociados a problemas de salud mental